on this blue collar coder we're going to
do an nx angular
module federation micro front end speed
run we're going to go
take two applications on nx both written
in angular
where one application hosts a carousel
and instead of extracting that carousel
into an npm module to share it we are
instead going to use
module federation to expose the carousel
from one application and then consume it
in the other for live updating it's
really fun stuff let's jump right in the
office
and get it done all right so here we go
we've got
our home page and our search page which
are two
different angularjs applications but
they're both
on the same nx repo which is fine
actually that's just
more out of convenience out of anything
else so
in this case we wanted the home page to
have exactly the same carousel up at the
top
as this search page we want to share the
two but we wanted it so that when
the search page which has the carousel
baked into it
does a deploy that the home page gets it
automatically
without a redeploy and that's a
run time dependency and that's the
critical difference between that and a
build time dependency
if this carousel were shared between
the search page and the home page as a
build time dependency
then both would need to be rebuilt and
redeployed in order for that change to
happen but in this case
the run time dependency case we can just
redeploy the search page with the new
code and the home page will
automatically get it let me demonstrate
that for you by jumping back over into
vs code
so here is the code for the pokemon
carousel which is this one right here
and i'm just gonna go and do a style on
that and give it a
border of a six pixel dash
red and hit save on that
and now because of live reload it's
automatically live reloaded on the
search page
because it knows that that code has
changed
but the home page live reload doesn't
know that the code has changed because
there's been no build there to redeploy
so i'm going to hit refresh now and
you'll see boom
now we get that component with that
change built in
so how did we get this going
well i followed primarily this article
on medium
about michael from ends with angular and
i what i did was i made a bit of a tweak
here
and instead of sharing routes i'm
sharing
components which i think is kind of a
little bit more interesting from the
micro front end perspective
so my version is over here in this
script
and that's linked to in the description
right down below
all right the first thing i'm going to
do is go into my temp directory and then
i'm going to run this nx
create workspace command and it's going
to create this aang
pokemon mfe directory it'll also ask me
what i want to put in there initially
and i want to put in an angular
application i'm going to call it search
and i'm going to say that we want sas
okay so the next thing i'm going to do
is go into that directory
and then bring up vs code and from here
i'm going to create
three different terminals
the first one is for the homepage that's
going to run the
server for the home page second one is
the search page it's going to run that
for the search app and then finally i'll
just make this one called terminal
and that's just going to run any random
commands so the next thing we need to do
is
generate the homepage app so i'm going
to do
nx generate and then say
the narwhal angular template app and
then give it home
i'm not sure why this doesn't ask me for
more options
like the other one asked me for like
sass and all this this one just says
like
do you want routing like yo no i don't
actually
okay now i'm gonna go into the apps home
directory
and i'm gonna add our dependencies we
need we need all
basically prime ng that's going to be
our component toolkit
for this example is prime ng just seemed
like a nice one
so i went for it all right now i need to
do the same thing over in the search app
okay now that's done in both now i'm
going to go and bring in the css for
this prime ng system
into both home and search so i'm going
to go over here and change the styles
just add in these prime ng css files
and then also get rid of the component
css
that is already there that's just going
to mess us up
so let's do the same thing over in
search
cool okay all right so the next thing to
do is bring in and register all the
modules from prime ng that we're going
to be using in both these apps
so let's go over into source app module
and then paste in this
so it's got browser module and panel
module
and button and carousel and input text
and all that great stuff so let's
hit save there and then go do this exact
same thing
over in app paste that in there
awesome perfect so the first thing i
want to do is set up the homepage app
so let's go bring in the html for that
that's going to go over an app component
html and replace their boilerplate
i'm going to save on that and then i'm
going to go into the home terminal
and i'm going to run the homepage app
all right let me bring that up in the
browser so we can see it
looks pretty good so far okay let's do
the exact same thing over
in the search app so the html here is
gonna be a little bit different it's
gonna have a search field on the side
it's also gonna show some pokemon
so i'm just gonna hit save on that and
now we need to go configure the
component
to go and set up all that data so i'm
going to define an interface for pokemon
and i'm going to say that this component
also extends on it
then within that component i'm going to
have some fields i'm going to have the
original pokemon data
the filtered pokemon data and that
filtering is going to happen based on
the search field which is going to be
using an
ng model so then i'm going to give
myself an
ng on init it's going to go and
hit this end point which is from github
so basically an old project that i had
that had some pokemon data in it
and because it's on github it's got the
raw endpoint so i can just go and grab
that
it's basically every pokemon has a name
it's got english on it
and a bunch of other stats you can feel
free to go and add on anything you want
into your
app i'm just going to keep it pretty
simple in this case
and then let's go and implement the
search callback this is going to take
that
pokemon source data that was loaded by
this fetch and then re-filter it based
on that new value for the search just
the same way that it does down here
okay so let's hit save and then we go
over into my
search terminal and i'm going to run
that search page
all right so we're up and running on
4201 all right
pretty good so we can type in you know
bul here and see all the different you
know
bulbasaurs whatever it is okay so now we
want to go and create a
carousel on the search page which is
going to be baked in
to the search page app so let's head
back to our terminal
and then paste in this command we're
going to generate
a angular component called pokemon
carousel
on the search project return and pretty
quick that one
actually so let's go and take a look
there
we've got an html and we've got a
component
so let's just go and add this into that
page
by just saying aang pokemon mfp pokemon
carousel
hit return
now we can see that pokemon carousel
works which is the content
of this html file right there
of course that's not what we want we
want a carousel so let's paste in the
code on that one
so it's going to require some images so
we need to go get those so let's take a
look over here
all right so we're going to go and again
define what pokemon is we're going to
have an input field here
so yeah second and we're going to have
an image and that image is going to
drive this carousel over here so
let's go and bring in first class fields
of images and that search
and then we'll replace the ngoninet and
i'll walk you through that
so this one is getting exactly the same
content as before
getting that data and then in this case
we are mapping and creating from that
pokemon data a simplified image it
basically just has the
image url and then the name then we
filter
based on this input which is search and
we slice that down to the top ten
so let's hit save and see how we're
doing oh
perfection looks pretty good so far okay
great so now we want to go and share
this pokemon component with the home
page and we're going to use
module federation to do that so first
i'm going to go ahead and
close down these two servers then we go
over my terminal
and i'm going to run this command i'm
going to add the angular architects
module federation
plugin to the search project on port
4201
all right now i need to do the same
thing for the home page app
exactly the same thing except for
project is home import is 4200.
i went a lot faster that time okay so
now we need to go and adjust our webpack
configs because module federation
is a feature of webpack and so we need
to go and adjust
the webpack and fake so let's go take a
look over in our
search page webpack config and we'll
scroll on down here
and i am going to uncomment the remote
section of this so
when you share something out you are a
remote
and when you consume something you are a
host
so in this case we are a remote now
what's really interesting in module
federation is
actually be both at the same time you
can go and share stuff out
and also consume it from other ones you
can even consume it from yourself which
is super cool
okay so but it doesn't know what we want
to share out so we want to share out the
carousel
component and we want to share it out of
pokemon
carousel
and that's the file and you can share
anything you want doesn't need to be
components it can be modules it can be
whatever
you want i'm gonna save that and
now we're going to go configure the
consumer side the host side over on home
go in here into webpack and now i'm just
going to uncomment out
hosts and this is actually right so this
is basically saying
i have a remote it's called search i'm
calling it search
locally and it's also exported as search
and it's on this remote entry file so
i'm going to hit save there
and then start up these servers okay
well if you run into any troubles where
home
or search doesn't run at this point what
you want to do is
remove the yarn lock and the package
lock from the top level as well as the
node modules and then
re-run mpm or yarn and that should get
you going
okay so now let's go take a look and see
if the applications are running
so it looks like they are but i also
want to go take a look at
remoteentry.js so this remote entry is
basically a manifest
of everything that the search
application exposes
and then the home page can go and then
bring this in
and it gets the carousel component it
wants to import so let's go do that
let's go over to the home page and we're
going to go and create a new wrapper
component
that wraps the imported component and
puts it on the page
so this is called carousel host and it
goes in the home page project
that was a lot quicker all right there's
our carousel host
and we're just going to go and add this
to the main page
and pokemon mfp carousel host okay let's
take a look
ah there we go carousel host works so we
know we have that component
so we're just going to go and remove all
the html and then we're going to go
paste in the implementation and i'll
walk you through it
okay so we're bringing in a lot of stuff
from the angular core to drive this
component but we're also bringing this
really cool
load remote module from our module
federation plugin
okay so what we're going to do on the ng
init is to load the remote module
using that remote entry and that name
and then that carousel component and
that's going to basically give us back
a module and with that we can then go
and de-reference pokemon carousel
component
which we then use through the component
factory to
create one and we're also going to go
and set
that search value on that instance
to p now we can set it to just nothing
let's give that try first and let's take
a look
holy moly wasn't that fast okay cool so
there we go
now that's exactly the same carousel
that's on our search page let's go take
a look
localhost 4201
very very cool right and i can go and
set that for example p
and that's just going to go filter down
those the stuff that's in the carousel
take a look ah very nice very cool so
you can actually go
and send data to that component just
like you would any other
angular component you've got so let's
finish this off
by showing you that runtime dependency
coolness like we did right at the
beginning
so i'm going to go back here to the
original carousel
i'm not going to touch home anymore
i'm going to go into pokemon carousel
and i'm going to change the html
implementation
all right so i'm going to do style and
let's see i'm going to do a border
of a 10 pixel dashed
red with a border radius
of 1em and a padding
of 1m all right so search has
automatically live reloaded this which
is great and now we're going to go over
to the home page
and it has not reloaded this because it
doesn't know
that it's changed and i hit just refresh
now we get it in that awesome that's run
time dependencies
using module federation on angular
really cool stuff as you can see webpack
5's module federation feature is a
game changer when it comes to sharing
code between applications and doing it
live
if you have more questions be sure to
put those in the comments section down
below
hit that like button if you like the
video and hit the subscribe button if
you want to see
more like this one